Hey Thoughty2 here, there is a tree called
the "Fruit Salad Tree" that can grow up to
7 different kinds of fruit on the same tree.
Welcome to RIF.
Andre "the Giant" Roussimoff once drank 119
beers in 6 hours.
He passed out in a hotel lobby but was too
large for anyone to help him return to his
room so he slept in the lobby all night.
If New York City were its own country, and
the NYPD was its army, it would be the twentieth-best-funded
army in the world, just behind Greece and
just ahead of North Korea.
A whopping 90% of Mozilla's revenue comes
from a contract with Google to be Firefox's
default search engine.
Madagascar was once home to an enormous flightless
bird, known as the elephant bird, it was three
times the size of an ostrich at more than
10 feet tall.
They existed as recently as the 18th century.
There are approximately three million shipwrecks
on the ocean floor, collectively worth billions
in value and treasure.
If you dissolve viagra in the water of a vase
of cut flowers, the flowers will stand up
straight a week beyond their natural lifespan.
There is a fruit by the name of Black Sapote
or "chocolate pudding fruit" which tastes
like chocolate pudding and is actually low
fat and has about "4 times as much vitamin
C as an orange".
The human heart can be replaced with two turbines,
causing a constant flow of blood rather than
a pulse.
The sun and moon appear to be the same size
because of an astonishing coincidence: the
moon is 400 times smaller but 400 times closer.
At a cost of $150 billion, the international
space station is the most expensive thing
ever built.